machine learning is being used to save
lives in the medical industry in this
course you will learn how to build and
evaluate AI models with tensorflow this
is a great real world project for
improving your machine learning skills
Dr Jason adelberg teaches this course he
is a radiologist in New York City and
also a programmer so let's start
learning hey everyone my name is Jason
I'm a doctor and computer programmer in
New York City and today we're going to
talk about how to build and evaluate
medical AI models with tensorflow
this tutorial today will have two parts
the first part is going to be building
and training a really simple tensorflow
model and the second part is going to be
going through the statistics the
evaluation of our model and we'll talk
about metrics like AUC sensitivity
specificity this stuff will be really
useful especially if you're interested
in deploying this in the clinical space
I want to give a big shout out to Dr
Walter Wiggins for inspiring this
tutorial here's his Twitter and here's
mine and with that let's get started
all right so today we're going to be
using Google collab Google collab is a
really cool website through which you
can run different parts of python code
um if you've never used it before it's
it's relatively easy
we'll start by clicking connect up here
and then
basically in this tutorial all these
different blocks of code here these are
known as cells
and we can click the play button here to
the left of it to get everything up and
running
this first cell I will just be us
downloading a whole bunch of things so
that's a good one to get started with
all right so today we're going to be
working with chest x-rays and chest
x-rays are the most common Imaging study
performed in hospitals in emergency
departments and outpatient settings it's
usually one of the very first things the
doctors want to know about if you're not
feeling well
now there are a number of things and
structures you can see on a trust x-ray
so let's just go over them real quickly
here's a normal chest x-ray you can see
the lungs you can see heart here in the
middle
you can see the aorta coming off of the
heart and supplying blood to the rest of
the body
you can see a number of skeletal
structures so for example here's your
collarbone or your clavicle
uh you can see all the ribs here on both
sides
you can see the vertebra here in the
middle
this line here is called your diaphragm
that goes around like that
and this separates your chest to your
thorax from your abdomen
um underneath this line is your liver
your spleen is over here
and this little kind of air bubble
sitting in here that this is your
stomach which in this case just has a
little bit of air in it and again this
is a normal chest x-ray
today we're going to be using a pretty
big data set of chest x-rays called the
nihc xr8 set and this is an open source
data set of a few thousand chest x-rays
which happens to have eight different
labels
so here's the eight different labels
available to us in this data set and
these represent eight pretty commonly
seen things on on x-rays
this is not everything that you can see
that can go wrong in a chest x-ray but
this is some of the more common things
and let's just go through them real
quickly
here we have atelectasis this is when a
little piece of the lung uh kind of
deflates a little bit
so that is up here basically this uh
wedge shape thing up here in the right
upper lobe
here we have cardiomegaly cardiomegaly
is when you have a really big heart
specifically it's when like this length
of the heart is more than 50 percent the
length of a rib to rib
and this is a sign of heart disease
here we have a pleural effusion that's
when you have something that's basically
sitting right outside the lung in What's
called the plural space which is not
really supposed to be full of anything
this one here this is an infiltrate and
that's when you have something sitting
inside the alveoli of the lungs it's not
supposed to be there there's a few
different things that can do that but
most the time this means that you have a
pneumonia
in this x-ray we have a mass
it's this rounded density up here in the
left upper lobe Apex or on top of the
lung
and mass is something that's more than
three centimeters in diameter and with
the mass you know again it depends on
the context but uh generally we're sort
of worried here about some sort of tumor
this is a nodule and a nodule is a mass
that's smaller than three centimeters so
this is a little bit harder to see
here's pneumonia a pneumonia is an
infection inside of your alveoli
again this is not like mutually
exclusive with infiltrate
and then finally last but not least this
is a pneumothorax and you know how in
this one we said uh you can have
Sometimes some fluid sitting in the
pleural space well here you have air in
the pleural space
and this is also known as a collapsed
lung
I bring all this up because some of
these conditions are a little bit easier
to see and some are a little bit harder
to see for example you can bet that a
mass which again is more than three
centimeters
um you can bet that that will be easier
for us to see than a nodule and so it
should be easier for a computer to see
this than to see this to see a nodule
you know basically how good our model is
is going to depend partly on the
technology that we're using but partly
on the data itself generally speaking
you know if you have more data that's
better if you have a higher diversity of
data like different types of nodules Etc
uh the model will work a little bit
better but the quality of the labels
really matters as well
so now that we've looked at the eight
different findings
um the e-label is available to us in our
data set let's choose one for the AI
model
so I'm going to choose cardiomegaly
and let's take a look at the data to
actually see kind of a little bit more
about the different images that we have
so I'm going to click here on the folder
button
and click here on the medical AI folder
and here on the images
and here's just a random one we'll open
up you can see that this is an example
of a chest x-ray up here
also in the data that we downloaded so
there's all the images there and then
here is a giant spreadsheet of all of
the images that we have available to us
with all the labels on them
so for example uh here are you know 100
or so images with the labels right there
in that column
I'm going to grab
a path for that file
and then put that in here
and then here's just another way that we
can make sure that
the python that our Google collab can
see everything this is showing just the
first five rows which happen to be
atelectasis
okay next I'm going to look for the rows
of this column where the label
equals our finding
and then we'll do the same thing for
where the finding is no finding at all
these are going to serve as negatives to
us
want to make sure that we have enough
images to train a model with here so for
this line here I'm just going to go
ahead and make sure
that we have enough examples of positive
cases so this is showing us that we have
146 examples of cardiomegaly that we can
use today and it's pretty good
now one concept for building a models is
that you want to separate the data into
a training set and a testing set usually
you do about 80 for training and 20 for
testing what does that mean so you know
the the AI model is going to get taught
is going to learn what's what from our
training data set but in order to tell
if it's working or not we want to show
it images that's never seen before and
that's going to be our testing data set
which is the other 20 of all those
images so I'm just going to manually
Define that right now just like this
and then I'm going to go ahead and spell
out exactly the number of images that
we're going to use for our training data
set
so I'm just going to say that that
number
is
um
80 percent
of what we have to work with today
and same thing for test data set
let's print those out just to make sure
that they make sense
and you can see that we're going to go
as you can see we'll use 116 positive
cases for our training data set and 29
positive cases for our testing data set
here you can see we have
quite a lot we have a lot of negative
examples so our limiting factor today is
going to be the number of positive cases
for this example today we're going to do
a 50 50 split where we want to have an
equal number of positive and negative
cases for our training and for our
testing so we're just going to spell
that out right here
thank you
so right here I'm just gonna
put together the rows that are going to
go in our training data set
that will look like this
and the same thing for our testing data
set
cool
okay great
all right so uh now that we know how
many images uh we have to work with now
we'll just move them to different
folders and we'll see a few examples of
the images with python to make sure
we're ready to go
okay so now we're just going to make
some directories
here is our root directory
with all the images in it
and then this is how I'm just choosing
to like make some new directories
so
make one like this for finding
we'll make one for our test data set
we'll make one for our
train data set
and then we're going to do the same
thing but just make a negative folders
instead of the positive folders two and
negative just means that there's no
finding at all
like that
now we're gonna go ahead and just move
those files over and we're going to do
this basically by iterating through like
the rows
in our data frame that we care about
so pay a little bit of attention to
exactly how many images we have to move
over
but here's where for example the
Training Positive examples happen to be
located
they are like this as it's defined
in our CSV file
here's where we're going to move it to
and this is again the way that we
defined it in the code block above
and then this line here this actually
does the moving
we'll try it real quick just to make
sure it works
it does we can double check by clicking
here
by going into images
waiting a minute
going into cardiomegaly and you can see
that now we've made some test folders
some train folders
and this should be a whole bunch of
images here right
now I'm just going to copy and paste
this
and instead of doing the positives and
our training data set we do the
positives and our testing data set
because
our training data set is 80 percent of
all of this like
this is more or less like the adbs
percent row right like of all the
positive things that we have and then
again we're going to move this to the
testing part so
I'm just going to tweak that right there
and then we're going to do the same
thing
for our negative so now I'm just gonna
again copy and paste those lines
I'm just going to change positives
to negatives
positive
it's negative
here and here
done
I'll go ahead and just copy this here
cool
now that we've moved everything over
let's just use Python to like show
everything directly in this notebook
just to make sure that what we're doing
makes sense and like is appropriate
so I'm going to Define two arrays
and then this is something that we
declared in the first blocker code when
we started today but let's just like for
emphasis describe that right here we're
just going to show like smaller versions
of the pictures that we're loading up
and then
we'll just show like six examples
and this is the way that we're going to
load it
into python itself
image.open image path
that resize
image
with
image height
image
like that
positive images append
and this is basically like a helper
function that we declared up at the very
top again
just like that
and I'll be sure that I spelled it
correctly
just going to do the same thing again
for the negative images
so again those are the the images that
have no findings at all
like that
like
that
now that we've actually loaded
everything we'll go ahead and uh
actually just like show everything with
matplotlib
and so we're going to go ahead and show
just six images
uh Sublime
so these will be our six images that
have cardiomegaly
that will go there
and then we're gonna do the same thing
I'm copy and pasting this for you know
negative images
so I'm just going to tweak that
I'm gonna tweak this
and we're not using again like the whole
point with the negative images to show
ones that have no finding at all so
let's go ahead and click play
here you can see that it's showing us
six examples of cardiomegaly from like
the folder that it's created and to me
these all look like definite cases of
card Omega you can see that the heart
here is for sure it's enlarged it's more
than half of the chest
and here these look like cases with no
findings so here the heart uh is normal
size and there's not really much else
going on as well
okay so now we have visualized our data
we've moved everything around and we
know that we want to build an AI model
for cardio regularly in this part we're
going to actually build the tensorflow
model
now there are lots of different ways to
approach model building and we can spend
an hour on this topic alone but
basically here I want to talk about two
different concepts for this part so the
first is called transfer learning and
the second concept is called Data
augmentation we're going to use both of
those things today
all right so this first line here
this is going to have us load our model
directly through power through
tensorflow itself
and we're just going to define the size
of the image that it's going to be
working with
which we kind of talked about earlier
but these are going to be kind of
smaller basically scaled down versions
of our chest x-ray
this three here is saying that basically
it's a three Channel image so like a
color image right like red green and
blue now it's true that
um
you know our chest x-rays are actually
just all Shades of Gray
um but we're just going to put that in
there because it's a little bit easier
and then this one here include top
equals false we'll come back to this but
this is basically going to let us
customize our model to do what we want
to do here
it should be Waits Pearl
and now we're using again the imagenet
network here
but what we're basically going to do is
on top of all this for the last layer of
our model we're going to have it spit
out whether it thinks there's card
omegaly or not
so we're going to just manually Define
that here this is um basically talking
about exactly
what type
of output we want our model to put out
so this is just getting that last layer
and here we're going to go ahead
and Define this by saying that we wanted
to say either basically yes or no
positive or negative
so this is the way that we can do that
this is just basically some stuff to
again help us with our big task which is
saying yes or no cardiomegaly or not
cardiomegalia you know all of these
decisions here like we could talk about
this for such a long time but I'm going
to kind of skip over uh exactly some of
the specifics here
and if there's any questions about this
I'm happy to take them out in the
comments
I also want to put an X in there right
okay as for the model
so now we have this model with a
slightly customized last layer
now we're just going to basically go
ahead and compile it
here we're just going to say
um that we're interested in the accuracy
basically so how accurate is our model
in between saying whether something is
positive or negative and that's sort of
the the metric that we're going to use
um
to help us figure out if our model is
working or not
oh and then one other thing is that we
should put an equal sign right in there
and that would help us as well
okay so now that this is all done now
we're going to go ahead and just Define
a bunch of things
uh
that are basically just kind of helping
Point our model to the right information
so if you remember from earlier all of
our images are hiding out right there
the directory where everything is
located for the Imaging
for the training stuff
is like this
for testing it's just about the same but
like this
change this here
and then this kind of keeps going so the
way we have our data structured is that
we have
uh like subfolders in our training
directory
that are called positive
one called negative
I'm sure we're going to put in right
here
looks like this
and then the same thing also exists just
for our test data
so I'm going to make these changes here
here
in there
I'll click play right there
okay so now the next concept I want to
talk about is something called Data
augmentation so as we discussed earlier
you know we have a bunch of images
available to us with cardiomegaly but
you know it's not like a ton
there are some ways that we can
basically kind of cleverly create more
training data for ourselves and that's
called Data augmentation
so what we're going to use here
is basically a really cool concept
called an image
data generator
and this is basically something that's
going to look at all the images that we
have and kind of tweak them a little bit
so that will be kind of generating like
more data from the data we already have
now there's a lot of different ways that
you can augment data that you can kind
of tweak data around but these are the
ones we'll just happen to use today
and you know if you're playing around
with this sort of on your own you're
welcome to you know kind of experiment
with different
ideas here so what are we doing so first
of all we're just kind of
um all these methods here basically are
generating extra images
that are slightly tweaked from our
images
so specifically this is going to
generate images that are slightly
rotated one way or the other
that are slightly shifted like stretched
out
that are sheared
um and that are zoomed in as well
one thing that's important with
augmentation for medical data is that
you know
um there's kind of some different
thoughts on this but when it comes to
flipping images you know a chest x-ray
is never really going to be flipped
around right like
um you know your heart is always going
to be
like uh you know your
you know when you take a chest x-ray
like it's always going to be right side
up right like your stomach's always
going to be below your lungs so if we
were to to flip the data upside down
that wouldn't necessarily really be
helpful for our AI model in regard to
horizontal flipping
um you know I think there's not really
like a consensus on this when it comes
to medical imaging or specifically chest
x-rays it's true that our bodies are not
completely symmetrical even though we
like to pretend there are so your
heart's a little bit more on your left
side there is a condition where your
heart can be more on the right side
um but it's not super common so I'm just
going to say that we're not gonna flip
things horizontally so that we don't
kind of confuse our model but that's a
choice that you could make if you wanted
to
for our test data we definitely don't
want to augment don't want to mess with
our test data at all
so this is just uh
a line where you know we are creating an
image generator but all that we're doing
here is just like
redefining the numbers that are inside
of our of each pixel basically so this
is um it's not really actually doing
anything right this is basically saying
that instead of each pixel going from
like 0 to 255 it's going to be between
zero and one
all right let's go ahead and click there
and that works
so that's image augmentation and now
this here is something that we need to
use in order to get our model to train
um called a train and chest uh train and
test generator
and this is basically the way that we do
it here
here so from directory which we already
have
Target size
and then we're just going to do the same
thing for testing right below
and then you know of course we just need
to kind of tweak some of these things
here for this particular part
I'm gonna go ahead and just Define the
number of steps that we're going to use
for this
um which is basically because we have a
batch size of one
um
it happens to be
the the same happens to be just like all
the images that we're using so I mean
this is one way of doing it like
the way that our data is structured
so again train steps equals the length
of that folder times two
and then for testing
we're going to go ahead and say that
it's like this
and then
actually type this in wrong here so
let's go ahead and just fix this real
quick
that goes like that
and then this goes like this
and you can see here that when we click
so it's found 232 images
for the training part and 60 images for
the testing part again that is pretty
close to 80 percent
um and 20 split
all right so we have everything set up
we have our model ready to go we have
our data ready to go this is the cool
part now we're finally going to run our
model and let it train
so in order to do that this is the
method that we're going to use we're
going to use what's called model.fit
we're going to point it to the train
generator
that we talked about earlier
we're just gonna mention exactly the
number of steps
per epoch
and an Epoch is basically one scan
through all the data so in this
particular example we're just going to
ask it to look at all the pictures 20
times
in order to do the training
and then we're also pointing it to like
the validation set that's our test set
the 20 that we sectioned off that has
not seen before
and when we click play you can see that
you can see that I spelled epoch's wrong
and finally it's going to actually start
to do its thing now the way that we
formatted it for like this tutorial
today it shouldn't really take too long
to go through all the data but this will
take about a few minutes or so so we're
just going to click play and then
basically step back and we'll come back
in a few minutes
all right so we're back it's been three
minutes of training which is really not
that much time at all but that's okay
that's enough for us to kind of
understand some of the concepts that
we're working with today
uh so now we're going to do is we're
going to see exactly how good of a job
it did over time
so basically we're just going to plot
how the accuracy changed and this is
basically the accuracy for the training
set which should go up
over time and then this is the accuracy
for the validation set the testing data
set which you know it hasn't seen before
so we hope that this goes up but you
know this is why we have to keep it
separate because this will actually show
us like if it's doing a good job or not
I do the same thing for
loss and basically loss is sort of
another kind of abstract way of thinking
about how good a job it's doing
so loss is basically you know you want
your accuracy to be going up over time
and you want your loss to be going down
over time
and loss is basically sort of a
mathematical way of talking about you
know the way that the network should
look and the way that the network does
look as it currently is
so I'm just going to plot using that
plot lib
some different uh stuff related to the
loss and related to the accuracy as it
changes over time
we'll do the same thing here before the
validation data set
and again this is going to be the
training
and test accuracy as it changes over
time
this in here like this
let's click play
and this is actually pretty encouraging
so you know as this thing ran for a few
minutes only after a few minutes it
started to figure out
um what was what what was cardamomegaly
and what wasn't so the training data set
we expect that to go up we expect that
to get more accurate over time
um but the testing data set we hope it
gets more accurate and as you can see it
did so when it first started it had like
a 50 50 chance but after just a few
minutes of training it got to be roughly
70 or so accurate and you know that's
better than flipping a coin
I'm also going to go ahead and just do
the same thing for loss
which again that's another way of
thinking about how good a job our model
is doing
um and so instead of accuracy we're just
going to plot loss
and I'm just gonna like change this here
so that we have a slightly better idea
of what's going on
so here's our loss as you can see this
goes down quite a lot over time uh we
could still you know we could zoom in on
this to see a little bit more but that's
kind of the basic idea here
foreign
so now that we've trained a model uh
let's see how well it does
and this section will basically have two
parts so first we'll just play around
with a few images to see like what the
model thinks and then we'll
systematically look through all of the
images with Statistics thinking about
things like sensitivity specificity and
AUC or area under the Curve
um you know I think that
kind of what distinguishes applications
of AI in medicine is attention to all
these details because uh I think that
you know these metrics are really
important when it comes to thinking
about whether you know this is really
something that's going to ultimately
help people
all right so let's start off with just
like two different helper methods
um this first one here is just going to
be a little helper method to load up an
image like this
we're going to resize it
to fit the size that our model requires
which looks like that
and we have to do an extra parenthesis
here
from here it's going to load it into a
numpy array
this is something we have to use
um just again to convert it from like
zero to 255 that is each pixel is going
to go from a value between 0 to 255 to 0
and 1.
this is just making sure that
the array has three different values for
like red green and blue
even though it's true we aren't really
using that because X-rays were like
usually all uh hopefully all in Gray
okay and then this line here
this is what's going to return so this
uh this line model.predict This is how
we're going to interact with our model
to actually return a value between 0 and
1 where 0 means that the model thinks
there's no finding and one means it
thinks there is a finding which here is
cardiomegaly
we're gonna do another like helper
method here and this is sort of like a
sanity check first
so what this is ultimately going to do
is this is going to show us an image
it's going to show us like the actual
file path that's associated with it
let's go ahead and load this up here
and then
because our model returns us a value
between 0 and 1.
what we're going to do is we're going to
Define some cutoff point
which here I'm going to say 0.5 where if
the prediction is above 0.5
then
uh the model is going to think that it's
positive right so in this case the mouse
going to think that has cardiomegaly
and this will make a little bit more
sense in a minute once we actually like
use this method but this is just
basically showing us like all of the
different information about the image
as we're doing the prediction on it so
this is the way that I'm going to just
access all of that information
guess Plus
four
okay
and then once we're down here
this will basically just use matplotlib
to go ahead and get all of that up and
running
let's go ahead and click play there
let's make sure that we
added all of the plus signs
and again you know one thing that's
really important is that we want to be
systematic in the way that we evaluate
all of our data
so what we're going to do here
is we're going to iterate through all of
the pictures all the images
in our test set
and basically try to just systematically
like or in an organized way figure out
what thought about everything this is
going to be really important when it
comes to getting things like sensitivity
and specificity which I'll come back to
in one second
all right basically what we're going to
do here
is we're going to go through all the
negative images so all the images in
which there was no uh finding it was
labeled that is as no finding
and we're just going to do predictions
on every single one of them
so we have this array called results
results array
and basically what we're going to do is
we're just gonna
uh create this kind of like results
array with all of the information that
we care about
so each row in the results weighs
results array is going to be the file
name like the image itself whether or
not it had a label being positive or
negative these are all the negative
images here so you know it's going to
have a negative label the guess so what
it happened to think
and then the confidence which again is
that number between 0 and 1 where we're
using like a 0.5 cutoff
for positive versus negative or
cardiomegaly versus not cardiomegaly
that first part was looking at all the
negative images
and now we're going to do the same thing
with all the positive images I'm just
going to change this down here because
again these are like positive labels
so at this point we'll have some array
with a whole bunch of stuff in it
a whole bunch of predictions for all of
the positive and negative test images
what I'm going to do here is I'm just
going to sort this array
um on basically that last column
which is like the confidence calm so
basically it's going to show us an order
what it really thought was
cardiomedically and then it's going to
show us
what I really thought was not
cardiomegle it was no finding at all
we're going to create a data frame from
all these results here
and then so that we can be
organized we are going to create like an
actual list of column names too that
would be helpful
name label
yes confidence
and then once we click this here it's
going to go through and basically just
make a guess on all the different images
in our test set
okay
let's scrolled
um again this
array that we created or this data frame
that we created
let's just take a sneak peek to make
sure that this like makes sense
cool and here's the first five rows
right so here's just five images in our
data set where these are like the five
images that our models thought were the
most
uh had the most cardiomegaly
all right so
you know that helper method that we did
earlier
where it was like a sanity check
to see if our model was actually working
let's go ahead and actually make a call
to that
so first we're just going to grab a
random number
um like from the test set
and then we're going to grab a random
Row from our data frame which is like
all the predictions on the test set
and this is that that helper method that
we used earlier right so here's a random
picture
um you can see that it was labeled as
having cardiomegaly and uh the model
guess that there was cardiomically
here's an example where this was labeled
as not having cardiomegaly I agree I
think that's a normal heart and our
model also thought there's no
cardiomegaly
here's an example where it was labeled
as having cardiomegaly and our model got
it wrong
here's an example where the model said
that there was cardiomegaly and it was
labeled also as carmichling just like
checking it out I think that's a pretty
big heart so I have to agree with that
we can click this button a whole bunch
of different times and see you know
whether or not it was accurate or not
but we can also use some numbers like
again sensitivity and specificity AUC to
help us uh also kind of get a better
feel for like if it's doing a good job
or not
so we'll get to that in one second but
let's just go ahead and show like the
entire data frame
uh right now or rather let's show like
every fifth row in the data frame just
to get another kind of feel
for what it had
so this is going to show like the name
of the file whether or not it was
labeled as a positive a negative
and then I was labeled as positive or
negative and basically like the
confidence that I had so I mean just
looking at this like really quick kind
of overview it looks like it did a
pretty decent job but some of the ones
here in the middle
I wasn't so sure about so in other words
you know when it was really confident
that there was cardiomegaly it got it
right when it was really confident that
there was not cargo megaly it got it
right but some of these ones in the
middle it kind of was a little bit iffy
so now I want to show the same
information in a histogram format and
this is good because this is going to
kind of start to guess to think about
some of those statistics that we
mentioned earlier
so this is the way that I'm going to
build the histogram
gonna grab the same thing
here for the negative labels
and then this is going to use like the
map lotlab histogram function
if negative
are those kind of a mouthful there but
uh just some more stuff
setting up this histogram chart
x axis
here
come on
title
confidence scores for different
uh images
and then make a legend
okay
Plot show
and here you can start to see
exactly how good of a job it did we'll
go ahead and just scoop this uh Legends
a little bit out of the way
and this is a little bit better right so
you know you can see that when the model
was pretty confident I got it right on
both sides right so like every every
example close to a one it got it right
over example close to a zero got it
right
um but in the middle it was kind of iffy
overall this is actually a pretty pretty
decent though in my opinion
so now let's go ahead and look at a
confidence score
so now let's think about you know
whether so you know
so earlier we had mentioned that you
know again the model is returning a
value between zero and one and we were
using like 50 or 0.5 as the cutoff so if
it was above 0.5 we would say that it
was positive that the model thought that
there was carbon regularly and if the
model returned a number between 0 and
0.5 we would think that it had no
finding
let's see if maybe that was the best
number for it to use
so here we're going to create a helper
function
called create with
cut off
that basically is going to kind of just
redraw our histogram but now we're going
to talk about false negatives false
positives
true negatives and true positives
so this line here
this is saying
let's find everything where it was
labeled
as positive
and
the model thought
that it was positive or it's thought
that the confidence value
was more than
that
this is going to give us an array of
like exactly all the confidence values
that are above our cutoff
let's do the same thing with false
positive
true negative
false negative
so for x
for
false positive that means that the
really the label was actually negative
but we thought it was positive
for true negative that means that
the real label was negative and our
model
um so that it was like lower than the
cut off
and I'm going to go ahead and just fix
this right here
before I forget
and then again for false negatives
finally
that's going to mean that you know this
was labels positive but
the model accidentally thought it was
less than our cutoff value
here we're just going to make another
histogram but we're just going to kind
of tweak it a little bit
so now instead of having
two different colors we're gonna have
four different colors colors one for
each of those four categories we talked
about
it's gonna be pretty similar otherwise
uh
um
and then all this stuff here is going to
be basically just the same as it was
last time so I won't go through
basically all this again
just going to type another title in so
confidence scores or
different images
this line here this is going to draw
like a vertical line
that helps us kind of differentiate
like where that cutoff value is and you
know come back to that in a second as to
like why we care about that
we're gonna put this in the upper right
all right and now this part here is
pretty important so now we're going to
calculate the sensitivity
so sensitivity basically is something
that we use a mess and a lot to see if
we should rule something in
so
like a screening test generally you want
to have high sensitivity for that and
the formula for sensitivity is true
positives over true positives plus false
negative so another way of saying this
is that something that's really
sensitive has a low number of false
negatives it might have a lot of false
positives so it might just think that
like everything is positive
um but at least we're avoiding false
negatives that way and then you know the
general scheme of things is that uh once
we have a confirmatory test
then we want High specificity
so for that it's kind of the other way
around where we want
there to be basically a low false
positive rate
so you know something that's like an
example of this like if you remember uh
you know in 2020 when we wanted to know
more about whether someone had coveted
you could use like the screening test
like uh sometimes that would be like the
self-swab test or a spit test I guess it
was a thing but ultimately the PCR test
was the most specific so that was like
the more confirmatory test
a lot of the screening tests would have
high false positives but the uh the PCR
test that was like a little bit more
accurate
but the
um the PCR test was like a little bit
more specific
here I'm just gonna actually like spell
it out
on the thing itself
all right and here
we're gonna go ahead and basically say
that we want to cut off of 0.5 so let's
try this out
okay
and as you can see
now that we've defined a cutoff of 0.5
now we can start to think about true
positives false positives true negatives
and false negatives
so here you can see that if we use a
confidence level of 0.5
um
we have a relatively low rate of false
positives but higher amount of false
negatives
let's see about if we change this value
to be something like that how does that
change or sensitivity and specificity
well if we lower that then we have
higher sensitivity but we have more
specificity
and basically the big picture here is
that a lot of tests in medicine kind of
struggle with this like you know how do
we Define a cutoff value for whether or
not someone has a disease you know for
example if you have diabetes you can get
a test called an A1C that basically
looks at the amount of sugar in your
blood over time
and you know what should the cutoff be
for someone who has diabetes or someone
who doesn't have diabetes Now the the
answer to that is 6.5 and a lot of
testing went in to figure out what's the
best value for for that particular test
but here we're kind of thinking about a
similar thing I mean what is the cutoff
for whether or not our model thinks you
have cardiomegaly or doesn't have
cardiomegaly and the kind of the
important concept here is that you know
we just arbitrarily chose 0.5 but that
might not actually be the very best
value
and a lot of issues uh
that might not be the very best value
and you know ultimately if our goal is
to build something that can look at a
chess X-ray and diagnose a disease we
want to be totally sure that whatever
cutoff value it has for saying yes or no
we want to be sure that it's the very
very best cutoff value
so for this next part we're going to
talk about Roc or receiver operator
curve which is related to AUC or area
under the curve and this concept is
basically how we can kind of figure out
what is the very best cutoff point for
this particular test for this particular
AI model which again is going to say yes
or no
so let's build a method to create an AUC
curve
and basically what an AUC curve is going
to do is it's going to do every single
possible
cutoff between zero and one it's going
to calculate the sensitivity and
specificity for all those possible
values
and uh
class certifications
and that's going to give us a lot more
information like through which we can
then figure out what's the best cutoff
value
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to feed this thing
classification so we're going to feed
this thing
um all of the
guesses that it made earlier we're gonna
have it like go through each one
we're gonna have it go through each one
and basically now create that AUC curve
so this is basically just going through
like all of the guesses that it had made
and we'll take it that way
foreign
so now we're just going to return
basically
all of the like numbers of true
positives false positives true negatives
and false negatives
we're going to manually calculate the
sensitivity which we talked about
earlier
we'll go ahead and do it this I like
this
specificity is going to be like this
all right so this is sort of the first
step
and then now that we've created
this function
you see curve
are sorted results
now basically from here
we're just going to create a line that
basically strings together like all of
these different sensitivities and
specificities for all these different
possible cutoff values
um
and now that we have all these different
values as well
we're going to make sure that
we calculate What's called the area
under the Curve
which basically like numerically
represents
how good of a model
uh this is or in other words it's
basically how close is our Roc curve to
being perfect
so here's just some code to create
heel line plot
Orange
all right there's the rest of color code
there
and now once we go ahead and run you can
see that our RSC curve is actually
pretty good has a pretty high area of
0.923
one thing that's kind of funky about
this curve about this this whole graph
is that you notice the x-axis here is
kind of like backwards like one minus
specificity the reason for that is
basically you know as sensitivity goes
up as a test becomes more sensitive it
gets less specific
so as the number of false negatives goes
down number of false positives is going
to go up
so
here you know like this point on the
curve up here this test is like super
sensitive which really just means that
it doesn't really have that many false
negatives
uh but you can see there's going to be a
lot of false positives so it's not going
to be as specific as it could be
overall this is a pretty good Roc
and you know given that we only train
this model for like three minutes and we
only fed it like 100 images instead of
like thousands of images this is pretty
encouraging you know if we were to redo
this experiment with like a way more
powerful model with like way more images
um
and with a lot more training time so
three minutes something like maybe you
know overnight or whatever uh there's no
reason why this Roc curve couldn't get
way closer to one but again 0.923 is
already like pretty good as it is
if you want to go ahead and save your
model that's pretty easy to do with the
code base that we're using you can just
do model.save
we'll save it to the content part
and we'll just go ahead and
uh put it like this so that you can find
it maybe a little bit more easily
you also might want to zip all this
stuff up and what's really cool about
collab is that you can do just exactly
that by hitting the exclamation point
when you start
in collab that allows us to do like
Shell Shell commands
so if you want to go ahead and try all
this here we'll click play
and in a minute you'll see that the
model is basically saved to here and
it's zipped up
I took like uh two minutes or so for it
it's a better thing up there but anyway
just click on this uh icon here and then
here's our model which is about a
gigabyte or so big click on those three
dots download and then that'll save it
to your computer and uh in a minute or
so
all right well that just about wraps up
this uh this presentation
um if you have any questions feel free
to reach me at that Twitter account uh
above or comment on this video below and
I hope you enjoyed that and uh thanks
for your attention thanks for your time